Here are the three solutions written in logarithmic form. Nice work, if you got
all three right. Now, some of these were tough, so it's okay if you didn't get
all of them right. Let's walk through each of them. For the first one, we'll
have our base be 10. And we'll have our answer be 5. When we take the log with
base 10 of some number, we'll get 5. It means that this number must be a
100000. The log base 10 of a 100000 equals 5. Its the power that we raise 10 to
in order to get a 100000. For the second one we'll use the same process. We
have a base of 4 so this is the logarithm with a base 4. The result of our
logarithm equals negative 3. Its the exponent and this is one sixty fourth here
at the argument for our logarithm. It's the number that we take the logarithm
of. And finally, for the last one, we use the same technique. Our base of our
logarithm is 2, since this base is 2. The result of our logarithm is x. This is
the exponent. And we're taking log base 2 of the number 3 to get x. Now, keep
in mind, in this last equation, we weren't really solving for x. We were just
trying to write this in logarithmic form. It turns out that this number x is
really equal to log base 2 of 3. Now the logarithm in your calculator can't get
this number. The log in your calculator has a base of 10. But there are other
ways to get bases of 2. We won't cover that in this course, but if you're
interested, do some research.